I you know I think it's just yeah I'm
not an answer you know anthropologist
but I think we're social beings were
interested in sharing things about
ourselves which you'll see on facebook
and myspace people tell the world
everything to learning interesting
things about other people and you know i
think you know from teenage girls
sending text messages gossiping about
each other which is blossomed into the
gossip girl book and TV show to our you
know infinite ability to learn more
about how many lattes Lindsay Lohan
drinks in today you know I think that's
sort of representative of the fact that
you know now we have this technology to
be able to do it I don't think we're
advancing by any means as a as humanity
that were consuming this information I
think we're just doing it because we can
we have this insatiable appetite
you